a geopolitical story of consequence that
developed over the last 24 hours which
is really just as much about reporting
as it is about foreign policy there was
were initial reports yesterday that
missiles had struck Poland and the
initial belief was this was Russia
probably accidentally in targeting
Ukraine
although it was not completely clear and
the belief now is that this was actually
an accident committed by Ukrainian
forces the latest reporting from CNN as
of this morning Poland's President says
missile that killed two likely fired by
Ukraine in defense against a Russian
attack
Polish president said the missile Polish
president Duda said the missile that
killed two people in eastern Poland
Tuesday was likely fired by Ukrainian
forces defending against the wave of
Russian missile strikes and that the
incident appeared to be an accident
quote there is no indication that this
was an intentional attack on Poland most
likely it was a russian-made s 300
rocket that was in a tweet he later told
a press conference there's a high chance
it was an air defense missile from the
Ukrainian side which fell on polish
territory in an accident while
intercepting incoming Russian missiles
Judas comments were in line with those
of two officials briefed on initial U.S
assessments who told CNN it appears the
missile originated in Ukraine although
it was Russian made
um this is important because listen
there's so many stories here number one
um
these military actions are serious
business and when we talk about
innocent bystanders
you're no more innocent if you're in
Poland where two were killed then you
are in Ukraine where the exact same
thing would happen either way when we're
talking about innocent bystanders we're
talking about innocent bystanders but
the unintended consequences
of an invasion of Ukraine by Russia
are extraordinarily far-reaching in ways
that aren't even always considered uh um
at sort of as the primary question or
discussion the second thing that's
important to mention is the amount of
misinformation and disinformation and
conspiracy theories that floated around
in the roughly eight to ten hours after
the original reporting was this seems to
have been Russia Russia bombed Poland
okay we saw all of the following and
more
we saw Fox News personalities say Poland
should bomb Russia in response you can't
let Russia get away with this well it
turns out it wasn't Russia turns out it
actually now can you blame Russia
because Ukraine is defending itself from
Russian aggression well okay you can
have that conversation but these Hawks
on right-wing media
saying anything short of immediately
bombing Russia back is unacceptable it's
weak it's [ __ ] whatever the case may be
Russia didn't actually do this this was
an accident from Ukraine based on what
we know right now that's number one
number two conspiracy theories I'm not
even going to play it I was going to
play it and I said why even bother
conspiracy theory Charlie Kirk saying I
don't know I I hope this isn't a false
flag I hope this isn't a false flag I
have no evidence that it's a false flag
but I just hope it isn't and one of the
things that unfortunately happens in the
24-hour news cycle and again this is why
sometimes I can't do it because the
story is so big but in the 24-hour news
cycle particularly when there are
shootings and crimes I will often wait
an extra day to avoid fueling
disinformation or conspiracy theories
and sometimes you just have to wait a
little bit particularly when the news is
coming from half a world away
not that there isn't internet and
Reporting in those places but we don't
always figure out exactly what's going
on right away so this is now another
dimension to what's going on in the
Russian invasion of Ukraine this has
been going on now for months and months
we don't know how long it's going to go
we still don't know what Putin's end
game is we still don't know what the
ultimate resolution is there are now
divided there have always been that
there are increasingly divided opinions
about for how long and to what degree
should or should the United States not
be uh funding Ukraine's defense be it
through money or be it through weaponry
and equipment and we are now in a nine
month conflict it's shocking to say but
it was I believe it was February when we
first started reporting on this we're
now almost in December I have no idea
what the conclusion of this is going to
be but what we do know is the longer it
goes on just simply from a sort of like
entropy and statistical perspective the
more likely it is that more types of
innocent bystanders are going to be hurt
and are going to be killed good uh use
of restraint by the way by many in the
United States not Fox News not Charlie
Kirk but by many in the United States in
actually waiting until we have more
information about exactly what it is
that happened there and it now appears
that it was actually an errant Ukrainian
defense attempt that ended up killing
two people in Poland what should the
geopolitical consequences of that be I
don't know and we don't yet know what
the parties involved are thinking huge
numbers of people report that CBD has a
calming effect that can help with
anxiety stress insomnia and our sponsor
feels is a premium CBD designed to help
you feel your best delivered right to
your door you just place a few drops of
feels under your tongue CBD can also be
a safe method for relieving minor aches
and pains without side effects the thing
to remember about CBD is that finding
the right dose is important and feels
even has experts on call to help you
with that over the phone if you need a
dose of Chill on the go you've got the
feels CBD infused mints and you'll get
fresh breath hard to complain about that
and with a feels monthly membership CBD
is simply a breeze you save money on
every order you can pause or cancel at
any time become a member today and get
50 off your first order with free
shipping when you go to feels.com Pacman
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below